buonasera a tutti
allora nel 1950 mentre mangiava con
alcuni colleghi fisici nella mensa del
laboratorio di los alamos enrico fermi
improvvisamente sollevò lo sguardo dal
piatto e domando dove sono tutti quanti
e non parlava degli altri commensali e
stava pensando agli extraterrestri era
impazzito no aveva fatto un ragionamento
nella nostra galassia
ci sono centinaia di miliardi di stelle
la maggior parte sono più vecchie del
nostro sole
le più antiche anno 13 miliardi di anni
il nostro sole la terra hanno 4 miliardi
e mezzo di anni
vabbè allora se la vita fosse apparsa su
qualche altro pianeta attorno a una di
queste stelle molto antiche quindi molto
prima che sulla terra potrebbero
esistere nella galassia specie
intelligenti incredibilmente più antiche
della nostra incredibilmente più
avanzate dal punto di vista tecnologico
con milioni di anni di vantaggio
rispetto a noi magari sarebbero già
viaggiando tra le stelle è però noi non
siamo mai stati contattati da nessuna di
queste ipotetiche civiltà intelligenti e
da qui la domanda di fermi appunto dove
sono tutti quanti
è una cosa insomma che che può creare
qualche curiosità può sconcertare e in
effetti nel corso degli anni sono stati
tentati molti approcci per rispondere a
questa domanda sono state proposte molte
possibili risposte alcune molto
fantasiose ma la più semplice è che non
c'è nessuno là fuori che siamo soli
ecco è possibile questo credo che questa
sia una domanda che ci siamo fatti tutti
quanti
prima o poi nella vita io almeno me la
faccio da sempre
quando ero bambino guardavo un cielo
stellato
mi chiedevo se attorno a quei puntini
luminosi potessero esserci dei pianeti
su quei pianeti degli esseri viventi che
magari proprio in quel momento stavano
guardando nella mia direzione si stanno
facendo la stessa domanda che mi facevo
anch'io
adesso faccio l'astrofisico mi
piacerebbe trovare una risposta
scientifica
a questa domanda siamo soli
nell'universo e io credo veramente che
trovare evidenza che c'è vita fuori
dalla terra sarebbe un cambiamento
epocale per la nostra specie per la
comprensione anche del posto che
occupiamo nell'universo quattro secoli
fa la rivoluzione copernicana ci ha
detto che non siamo fisicamente al
centro dell'universo non c'è nessuno al
centro dell'universo perché non c'è un
centro nell'universo un secolo e mezzo
fa charles darwin ci ha spiegato che la
nostra specie è imparentata con tutte le
altre specie del pianeta in realtà
veniamo discendiamo tutti da un unico
antenato comune e appunto trovare
l'evidenza scientifica dell'esistenza di
altri mondi abitati io credo che sarebbe
una terza grande rivoluzione
paragonabile forse addirittura superiore
alle altre due per portata bene negli
ultimi anni abbiamo sicuramente fatto
molti passi avanti nella direzione di
una possibile risposta ancora non ce
l'abbiamo
una risposta però noi siamo i primi
esseri umani ad avere le prove
scientifiche che ci sono pianeti intorno
ad altre stelle
questa è una delle grandi novità
dell'astrofisica degli ultimi 20 anni
venti anni fa avremmo potuto sospettarlo
che ci fossero altri pianeti da fuori ma
adesso abbiamo le prove
conosciamo migliaia di pianeti intorno
ad altre stelle ormai e ipotizziamo che
molto probabilmente ogni stella della
nostra galassia
abbia almeno un pianeta quindi stiamo
parlando di numeri giganteschi centinaia
di miliardi di pianeti da fuori e dei
veneti che conosciamo in realtà sappiamo
anche che molti di loro si trovano alla
giusta distanza dalla loro stella per
avere una temperatura che consentirebbe
la presenza di acqua liquida quindi di
marie di oceani sulla loro superficie e
questo è uno dei requisiti che noi
riteniamo indispensabili per la vita
come la conosciamo
addirittura secondo alcune stime
statistiche potrebbero esserci nella
nostra galassia 11 miliardi di pianeti
potenzialmente adatti alla vita
sottolineo il potenzialmente perché
stiamo veramente muovendo i primi passi
quindi non abbiamo ancora evidenze
definitive che uno di questi pianeti sia
effettivamente abitabile però abbiamo
strumenti che li stanno studiando li
studieranno e nei prossimi anni dalla
debole luce che ci arriva da questi
mondi lontanissimi riusciremo a capire
tante cose a capire per esempio se hanno
un atmosfera di che elementi è fatta
questa atmosfera e quindi a capire se
effettivamente ci sono le condizioni per
la presenza della vita e addirittura in
un futuro non troppo lontano potremmo
scorgere in questa luce delle delle
tracce degli indizi che potrebbero dirci
che si in effetti uno di questi pianeti
potrebbe essere abitato io spero che
tutti noi possiamo essere testimoni
nell'arco della nostra vita di momento
del genere perché ripeto credo veramente
che sarebbe un cambiamento epocale per
tutti noi
una delle domande che potremmo farci e
che spesso in realtà viene fatta e li
raggiungeremo mai questi altri pianeti
e la risposta non preparate le valigie
no perché sono incredibilmente lontani
sono separati da noi da un oceano di
spazio vuoto l'universo è veramente
molto grande e allora vi do un esempio
un esempio concreto questa sonda alle
mie spalle la voyager 1 è il veicolo
spaziale costruito dall'uomo che si è
allontanato di più dalla terra è in
viaggio da una quarantina di anni è
arrivata ai confini estremi del sistema
solare è entrata nello spazio
interstellare
e si sta allontanando dal sole a una
velocità pazzesca 60mila chilometri
all'ora 17 chilometri al secondo
quindi una velocità enorme ma appunto
quanto ci metterebbe questa questa sonda
spaziale per arrivare alla stella più
vicina alla nostra proxima centauri se
stesse viaggiando in quella direzione
ci metterebbe 74.000 anni che è un tempo
più lungo di quello di qualunque civiltà
umana sia esistita sul nostro pianeta
potremmo fare di meglio in futuro certo
potremmo fare di meglio ma anche la luce
che viaggia alla velocità massima
consentita in natura impiega più di
quattro anni per fare questo percorso e
le altre stelle sono incredibilmente più
lontane di così quindi anche
semplicemente comunicare via radio con
altri sistemi richiederebbe centinaia o
migliaia di anni dal rinvio del segnale
la ricezione di una risposta e quindi è
tutto molto complicato forse non siamo
soli nell'universo
ma sicuramente siamo parecchio isolati
siamo persi in un mare in un mare di
spazio vuoto
e allora secondo me qui c'è una delle
cose da tenere presente quando si tenta
di dare una risposta all'interrogativo
di fermi che poi l'interrogativo in
realtà che abbiamo tutti noi ovvero dove
sono tutti quanti e il fattore da tenere
presente è il tempo quindi parliamo del
tempo e uso un esempio dello scrittore
john mack fi la distanza tra la punta
delle dita della mia mano sinistra e la
punta delle dita della mia mano destra e
il tempo trascorso tra la formazione del
nostro pianeta la terra e oggi 4
miliardi e mezzo di anni
benissimo le prime forme di vita
unicellulari gli antenati appunto di
tutte le forme di vita mai apparse sul
nostro pianeta inclusi noi stessi beh
queste compaiono abbastanza presto
compaiono qui da qualche parte nel palmo
della mano sinistra
poi questi microrganismi batteri
dominano la vita sulla terra per
moltissimo tempo si replicano si
differenziano grazie alla selezione
naturale l'evoluzione è solo qui al
polso della mano destra cioè
l'esplosione delle forme
degli organismi multicellulari quelli
più complessi fatti da una rete di
miliardi e miliardi di cellule gli
animali le piante i dinosauri dinosauri
appaiono qui alla fine del palmo della
mano destra e all'inizio dell'ultima
falange un evento naturale catastrofico
molto probabilmente l'impatto di un
grande asteroide li spazza via dalla
terra insieme a tre quarti delle specie
viventi in quel momento sul pianeta ed
estinzioni di questo tipo piccole grandi
ci sono state moltissime volte nel corso
di questa lunga storia della vita sulla
terra addirittura si calcola che il 99
per cento delle specie mai vissute su
questo pianeta sono estinte e quindi
questo ci dà un'idea del fatto che
questa lunga storia il cammino
dell'evoluzione della vita sulla terra è
stato un percorso lungo difficile
accidentato governato da eventi
imprevedibili e che quindi non doveva
portare necessariamente all'origine
degli organismi più complessi non doveva
dell'intelligenza e meno che mai doveva
portare alla comparsa della nostra
specie homo sapiens
ecco appunto noi in tutto questo dove
siamo
bene tutta la storia dell'umanità sta
nella punta di un'unghia potremmo
cancellarla via completamente con un
colpo di lima e questo è già successo
perché noi oggi sappiamo che per decine
di migliaia di anni sul nostro pianeta
hanno convissuto con noi
altre specie umane che non ci sono più
come i neanderthal e allora qui forse
c'è un po la chiave di tutto quanto se
un giorno come io spero scopriremo che
c'è altra vita nell'universo è molto
probabile che si tratterà di
microrganismi i primi extraterrestri
potrebbero essere dei semplici batteri
la galassia potrebbe essere dominata dai
microbi le specie intelligenti
potrebbero essere rarissime e persino la
loro esistenza potrebbe essere
brevissima trascurabile rispetto ai
tempi della vita ai tempi dell'universo
magari sono le stesse specie
intelligenti una volta raggiunto un
certo livello di progresso tecnologico
ad auto auto annientarsi oppure
semplicemente implodono collassano
spariscono senza lasciare
nessuna traccia nell'universo allora
forse questo grande silenzio cosmico che
ci sconcerta e ci incuriosisce forse
anche un po una specie di avvertimento
forse ci sta dicendo qualcosa la vita ha
dovuto superare un gran numero di
barriere per arrivare fino a dove siamo
oggi ma la barriera più grande potremmo
averla davanti a noi nel futuro dopo
tutto pensiamo a noi stessi alla nostra
specie da lontano immaginiamoci visti da
un altro pianeta
se noi sparissi mo domani probabilmente
nell'universo nessuno se ne sarebbe mai
accorto che che ci siamo stati siamo una
specie giovanissima da appena un secolo
abbiamo cominciato a volare ea
comunicare via radio da una cinquantina
d'anni manda mandiamo sonde nello spazio
siamo arrivati ai confini del sistema
solare però veramente abbiamo appena
messo la punta del piede in questo
grande oceano del cosmo che ci circonda
io penso che fermarci qui sarebbe
veramente un peccato e noi a differenza
dei dinosauri abbiamo almeno in parte la
possibilità di cambiare influire sul
nostro destino
abbiamo sicuramente la capacità di auto
annientarci però abbiamo anche come io
credo e spero la possibilità di usare la
conoscenza scientifica e la tecnologia
per affrontare e superare i problemi che
ci troveremo davanti per garantirci un
futuro lungo in cui continuare a
scoprire cose meravigliose sull'universo
magari un giorno la vita su qualche
altro pianeta
e chissà magari gli un futuro
lontanissimo per fino a raggiungere le
altre stelle poi se là fuori ci sono
delle super intelligenze galattiche come
si vedono nei film di fantascienza
allora l'unica speranza di farne parte
del club di queste intelligenze
galattiche di sopravvivere il più a
lungo possibile teniamo duro se poi
invece fossimo soli
in tutto questo spazio beh allora io
credo che ancora di più abbiamo il
dovere di mantenere accesa fin che ci
riusciamo questa debole meravigliosa
fiammella di consapevolezza apparsa per
caso in un piccolo pianeta perso nel
buio del cosmo grazie